E PROCESS?
WAS IT GRUELING?
WAS IT ETIME CONSUMING?
HOW MANY HOURS WERE YOU SPENDING
A DAY TRYING TO GET THAT KNEE
READY?
GIANNIS: 24.
24.
FOR MY TREATMENT, LIFTING, FROM
GETTING ON THE COURT.
POOL SESSIONS.
YOU KNOW, KEEPING MY FOOT
ELEVATED.
24 HOURS A I A DAY.
OBVIOUSLY IT WASN'T EASY BUT I
WAS WILLING TO DO IT.
I THINK THE MEDICAL STAFF HAD A
GREAT PROGRAM FOR ME THAT I WAS
ABLE TO, YOU KNOW DO, WHAT I
HAVE TO DO TO GET -- TO STAY IN
SHAPE.
AT THE SAME TIME RECOVER AND YOU
KNOW, NOT HAVE A LOT OF SWELLING
IN MY KNEE.
AND YOU KNOW, I WAS DECLARED TO
PLAY, I FELT GOOD.
MY KNEE, NOT FEELING PAIN, THE
SWELLING WAS DOWN, SO IT WAS OK,
GOOD TO GO.
REPORTER: I DON'T THINK WE
BELIEVE YOU ABOUT THE PAIN THING
BUT I WONDERED --
GIANNIS: WHY?
REPORTER: BECAUSE WE KNOW YOU.
BUT IT'S OK, WE UNDERSTAND.
DID YOU SEE THE VIDEO OF YOUR
INJURY?
AND DID THAT WRAP YOU HAD HINDER
YOUR RANGE OF MOTION AT ALL?
GIANNIS: NO.
I'M TRYING MY BEST HERE TO NOT
MAKE IT ABOUT MY KNEE BUT I'M
GOING TO SAY ONE MORE TIME THAT
MY KNEE FELT GOOD.
OBVIOUSLY, WHEN YOU GO AND PLAY
A GAME YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I PLAYED -- THAT PLAY WITH JAY
CROWDER, COULD HAVE HAPPENED
WITH ANYBODY, NEVER KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I'M HAPPY TO BE OUT THERE, HELP
MY TEAMMATES ANY WAY I CAN.
I'M JUST TRYING TO PUT MY
ATTENTION ON THAT.
NOT IF MY KNEE HURTS.
I -- AT THE END OF THE DAY I'M
OUT THERE I FEEL GOOD.
I DON'T FEEL PAIN.
I CAN RUN, I CAN JUMP.
I G CAN SET SCREENS.
I CAN DO STUFF.
SO I'M GOOD.
I'M HAPPY.
I'M HAPPY THAT I'M OUT THERE AND
YOU KNOW, AT THE END OF THE DAY
I HAVE -- I THOUGHT I WAS GOING
TO BE OUT